i would say that in the current and
foreseeable future
and this is a nato formulation in the
final act which was signed with nato in
the 90s a long time ago
that we have no intention to do that so
it means that we have no intention to do
that at all
and it has been said on different levels
of course okay no intention to do that
what then are the
100 000 or more troops doing massed
along the ukrainian border with russia
what are they there for what is their
purpose many are saying that nato is the
security arrangement for europe now this
is not true nato is one factor of
security the other factor of security
this is russia
and for a long time we have had a
balance on the european situation
but then a nato has started to
aggressively expand to the east
enlargement is a dangerous thing that
has been accompanied by many offensive
actions aggression
of nato are in former yugoslavia now
former but at the time it was yugoslavia
then it was an aggression to iraq
uh libya
syria
all of this is not pure nato but it used
a consultative mechanisms uh
support by nato at launchpad as a
platform so we find that nato is
conducting increasing behavior this is
serious it is coming closer and closer
to our borders so now it is nearly
it has promised to
accept ukraine as a member and we see
that there is a closer cooperation
between nato and ukraine we are seeing
many ships coming into the black sea
exercising over there uh aggressively as
well we see a lot of aircrafts military
aircrafts
and we see that nato infrastructure and
a large masses of nato troops are moving
to poland
preparing new launch pads over their new
infrastructural sites so
it is dangerous for us it contains a
risk of a large-scale war that is why we
need to act certainly and of course we
are moving troops troops are exercising
and it is no secret that they are
preparing to deter any kind of threat
okay well you say a risk of a
large-scale war let me refer you back
then to your first answer no intention
of invading ukraine but
if the perception from the russian side
is that the threat from nato as you
characterize it increases
then russia may
invade russia may engage with ukrainian
forces i have i haven't said that
but we see that nato is pushing ukraine
to be more and more uh aggressive in a
sense so we do not want and we don't
just envisage a possibility of that and
we are doing everything to diminish
these risks and to take these risks out
of pictures some would say that it's not
diminishing the risk to to position many
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of of troops and armor and
their support
along that border that that's not
minimizing risk isn't that increasing it
no no i wouldn't say so so the city's
troops are in maneuvering they can be
here there and now it is not the one
group of forces it is dispersed all
around but we have seen similar
situations already in 2008 when nato has
promised to georgia to took georgia as a
member in it and georgia has become very
aggressive and they started an
aggressive behavior towards south sushi
and apresia and it was this risk has
turned out into a very serious event
well let's get into that
characterization from the russian side
of nato's intentions
nato exists as a defensive alliance we
don't need to go back into the history
we all understand that it's a defensive
alliance and sovereign nations of which
ukraine is one sovereign nations are
free
to apply to join it it's as simple as
that nato does not engage in aggressive
actions
i just explained it was an original
intention of nato to be a defensive
alliance since that time it has done
many aggressive steps so this is not
true then nato does not exist in limbo
it does not it exists inside europe
and it's a function of existence of nato
it is its relationship with russia
and i also should say that
leadership of countries of members of
nato has not only signed the washington
treaty they have signed many obligations
other obligations this is a
helsinki charter 75 this is a paris
charter 19 and this is istanbul
agreement on european security all of
them were saying there are principles of
that indivisibility of security one
cannot increase its security for the
sake of the others
well all states should feel secure over
there so it's about equality we even try
to construct all european heroes at some
point in time
but then it has been all abandoned
unfortunately can i just ask you that
point i made does russia accept that
ukraine is a sovereign nation free to
choose whether it joins nato or the eu
or indeed perhaps the russian-led
security alliance free to choose which
organizations it joins
every state uh will behave the way it
feels uh uh which will be in accordance
of its interest but at the same time at
the same time every state if it is
normal will take into account eastern's
interests of neighbors its history its
situation economical situation and all
the all factors should be in view not
only one because a nato leadership
united states has promised to take it
into
ukraine and georgia into nato it doesn't
mean that it will be totally good for
them our opinion that it will be
worsening a forty it will be worse for
the european security it worsen position
of all states in it and it contains a
risk of a war
but russia has gone to these talks
and presented two draft treaties as if
the negotiations had already taken place
and more or less said to the united
states said to nato just sign here we
will not negotiate on these lines about
nato expansion that surely is not a way
of negotiating and it suggests that
russia wants the negotiations to end
it's an ultimatum
i don't think so uh it's a long story as
i explained it to you so the story a lot
since uh 1997
and uh about expansion of nato
at that time earlier in early 90s we
have heard we have had promises
assurances uh good wishes and all of
that stuff now this premise has been
abandoned and we have now a long uh
history of uh americans abandoned
withdrawing from the agreements that
they have signed this is paris agreement
on climate inf treaty
iran deal uh open skies i can continue
but as you know the new administration
your administration is prepared to
discuss
where they affect russia prepare to
discuss re-establishing those well come
on and next administration when it will
come it will say that
we do not believe to into the treaties
that has been concluded by this uh
democratic administration that is why we
are saying only legally serious
guarantees put on paper that guarantees
of non-enlargement of nato can satisfy
us
second second second this is a very
important point ambassador because it
gets to the nub of the russian position
the russian position is in effect that
you can't trust the united states
because it seems unstable to you because
of constant changes of administration
and then therefore changes of attitude
towards its international
answering your own treaties well i'm
putting this to you well you accept that
i'm putting this to you and that
therefore
russia needs to sign a deal with nato
not the united states to stop its as you
describe it to stop its expansion you
can't trust the united states it's a
matter of negotiations uh this is in our
proposed draft or agreement with nato
but of course uh we should also talk to
the united states certainly because when
i was working in the in his headquarters
of nato it was called u.s nato
that's a form of
actually a coexistence of european
states originated and of course u.s is
in a way his most important player over
there and it is determining the major
position
uh and of course uh that's just i say i
cannot i wouldn't go as far as saying
that we do not trust them we are not uh
in a way as americans some american
diplomats are trying to say uh to to
spoke in this language uh so we are
diplomats and we are serious when we are
talking but we need legally binding
guarantees that no striking weapons will
be put along our borders uh that all
these capabilities will be removed back
and we shall come to the situation uh it
we did have this situation in the
90s in fact when we have principles on
which we have a totally peaceful queen
existence
and some may say it sounds a bit strange
this attitude to nato coming from
rasharan indeed from president putin at
the moment given that some
in the year 2000 apparently
at the early stages of his presidency um
vladimir putin was thinking about asking
to join nato for russia that from uh
george robertson the then
uh nato secretary general that russia
was considering applying to join nato
well
i know george rupertson uh at this time
we used to work together he was
secretary general and i was a minister
counselor in need we have met with him
several times and we discussed that
situation
there was something in the air an idea
not borne by us probably it has been
borne by some politologists about russia
joining to nato but in fact it was not
realistic
at that time and later on so
there are realistic things and there is
non-realistic things
later on uh say things has changed nato
has changed as well and instead of going
like that we have gone like that
okay let's talk more about these
negotiations then so these are the
russian position we've seen it as i say
in those draft treaties and you will
have been hearing from the united states
you'll hear it from nato as well well
okay you put that on the table then we
are putting on the table our position
which of course is
no more threats towards ukrainian
territory
crimea the position of crimea must be
discussed as well and also as we've
discussed before ambassador the cyber
attacks on european soil the
assassination attempts in many capitals
these also must be discussed
i see that there are two questions in
your uh in your question sorry sorry for
that uh one is uh what will be the
outcome of the nato russia uh council uh
tomorrow and talks with it the worst it
will be if uh we shall get uh as it
happened in the recent years uh only a
repetition of the same position by other
member countries russian nato council
was not created for this russia nato
council was created for discussion among
members
discussing and finding solutions to it
discussing and finding common elements
of positions that can be transformed
the worst about this question is that in
the recent years it was only one-sided
presentation of position to nato which
was presupposed was to teach us
how to behave it is wrong
second about the other question cyber
attacks
and all of that you know that there are
two perception of security the no of the
uh
rigid security means what we are doing
now it is security about armament about
nato about uh necessity to take into
account uh security interest another is
soft security which includes quite a lot
of things economics culture human rights
here you can you can
go anywhere
but it doesn't help unfortunately it
does not allow us to concentrate on on
things which we need to resolve
and lastly ambassador can i ask you for
your response um to the ukrainian
position about um the threat that russia
poses i spoke to the ukrainian foreign
minister not so very long ago who said
to me that if russia
should send its troops into its
territory there will be russian bodies
littering the streets of the towns and
cities of ukraine
we could we heard this phrase
this argument it is i do not intend to
commend uh them because it is very
hypothetical position we have said that
we have no intention to go there we have
enough we have no intention to send
troops over there so whatever he is
going to say it is in his imagination
which is i would say nothing but very
very uh torn out of reality
mr ambassador thank you very much indeed
thank you thank you denman